nous retrouvons en ukraine notre
correspondant et gulliver craag
l'univers où en sont les combats sur le
terrain ce vendredi en ukraine
alors en même temps que vladimir poutine
avait ses déclarations très belliqueuse
le porte parole du ministère de la
défense russe a annoncé une pause dans
l'offensive dans le donbass pour se
regrouper cette pause ne s'est pas
vraiment manifesté sur le terrain les
forces russes continuent à faire de
petites avancées sur le sol en partant
de la région de luhansk vers la région
de donetsk donc à l'ouest de licite
chose que mais dans d'autres directions
plus vers le nord les forces qui essaye
d'avancer vers le sud depuis la région
dach qui veulent par exemple selon les
militaires ukrainien ils sont
systématiquement repoussés mais les
bombardements de toutes les villes sur
la ligne de front continuer avec
notamment une frappe sur le centre-ville
de cramât tort ce qui est maintenant la
plus grande ville dans le dôme basse
contrôler encore par l'ukraine hier
néanmoins les ukrainiens craignais une
intensification de ces de ses offensives
l'annoncent d'une pause est interprétée
avec optimisme chez certains
commentateurs qui disent que cela doit
sans doute vouloir dire que les russes
ont effectivement subi des pertes
significatives et notamment des pertes
au terme de leurs stocks de munitions
les ukrainiens commencent à utiliser les
systèmes américains hymers avec un effet
avec succès ils ont détruit de
nombreuses dépôt de munitions dans le
dôme base de dépôts de munitions russe
et donc cela crée une ambiance d'un peu
plus d'optimisme en ukraine par rapport
à ce qui se passait ces derniers jours
il y avait la crainte qu'elle est russe
allait commencer à avancer vraiment très
vite après la d'après les sites inscrits
l'ukraine par ailleurs gulliver qui a
déploré le départ de boris johnson
oui boris johnson était extrêmement
populaire en ukraine il y a toujours
cette crainte en ukraine que
soutien occidental à ce pays pourrait
diminuer benoît laisse le secrétaire de
la défense du royaume uni a rassuré les
ukrainiens qu il n'en serait rien que ce
soutien du royaume uni à l'ukraine
continuera après le départ de boris
johnson un soutien qui était aussi
renforcé par la visite à kiev hier de
deux sénateurs américains lundi crème
eric blum entoure donc un républicain et
un démocrate qui ont notamment annoncé
leur initiative de faire passer une
révolution une résolution excusez moi au
sénat pour désigner en russie comme un
état terroriste c'est vraiment le genre
de propos que les ukrainiens ont tout le
temps envie d'entendre pour être plus
rassuré que ce soutien qui est si
cruciale pour leur effort militaire va
continuer merci oui l'hiver